[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là les quatre tirs de jean
luc roy je sais que tu aime beaucoup
cette section et bien je sais vous
l'adorez et notion-là dorment
aujourd'hui
merci d'être lente ou alors juste un
plaisir on va rappeler une voie selon
lui qu'un comme je dis chaque année
grâce ouais il voit tout et c'est vrai
que les séquences qu'ils sont bonnes
pour vous téléspectateurs mais un petit
peu plus difficile pour nous membres de
tenir il ya une question pour le
meilleur ami de nabila justement ce soir
très bien bonjour ce matin jean r la
semaine dernière j'ai regardé une
émission à ma grande surprise jean
michel mr a articulé sa main et piété
est il malade qu'est ce qui se passe je
commençais question chère genève qu'est
ce qui se passe parce que c'est une amie
québécoise et bien compris nous a tous
surpris la semaine dernière on s'y
attend pas et hop on voit notre pote qui
articule à tous super produit mais
rassurez vous si ce n'était qu'un
accident
plus sérieusement il faut savoir que
jean michel jean michel est un articule
très bien mais hors antenne
nous on est plutôt calme avant
l'émission publié dès le départ il ouvre
grand le robinet à caudry c'est une
horreur
non mais il part dans tous les sens et
surtout il part tout seul vous allez
comprendre
c'étaient les jours de la première
d'aurore castaldi alors quitte aussi la
femme d'un de nos chroniqueurs mais je
peux pas vous dire qu'il est pour des
raisons de discrétion
en fait j'aime bien le rapport mais
l'émission commence bien et tu ne porte
la poisse prochainement retour chaque
noix je vais très bonne chose tous les
retours façon t'es pas là pour être
intelligent siri tuberie un peu de
poudre passé il a fait six axes il est
bon et juste on peut faire un chef et
non mais vraiment ça c'est allah pour
que valérie benaïm lâche un ta gueule
c'est que le mec est vraiment usant
ouais c'est vrai donc ça c'était lundi
dernier quand ni ce qu'elle était venue
chanter son tube réseau enfin avait
essayé de chanter car je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais on n'avait pas
de son pourquoi parce qu'un mec avait
débranché un cas pour brancher son
portable
c'est vrai il ya un gars il a vraiment
des brosses et le cab annoncé stephen à
quoi ça tient là que sur ses 8 ans on
reçoit des disques de platine et
l'artiste peut pas chanter parce qu'avec
de recevoir un texto pour voir ce qu'il
a mangé soir donc cyril est intervenue
il est parti en régie et le son est
revenu au moment où on a lancé la pub
sauf qu on l oublie le dire à nice cap
[Musique]
c'était bien
c'est la pub là
[Musique]
l'artiste
[Applaudissements]
c'est que la cure bout du rouleau sais
pas je le rappelle il entretenait mois
au bout du rouleau et la raison serait
que pierre bachelet à chaque fois qu'il
n'a tpm pessah filer droit
au final heureusement disque a pu
chanter son morceau pour le plus grand
bonheur de benjamin échoue michel qui
adore les chansons à texte un tas d'or
[Musique]
devant lui
c'était dingue et toulouse mais la
raison c'était vraiment les to follow
dow à épouse liu pelouse il ya des
génies dans l'équipe j'ai d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que c'est une zone des
pancartes pour nous exprimer ses vies
que moi ont parlé mardi de conneries
c'est bien c'est bon on n'a pas été
formés au cirque de pékin non plus si on
n'est pas en couleur une pancarte ça va
mais là heureusement c'est abusé
regardez la détresse des chroniqueurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sait plus où on a laissé beaucoup de
points car il est comme ça si c'est ce
qui est bien pour son émission c'est
vrai les points car c'est bien se moquer
du pape par contre c'est beurk c'est
kaka mais s'il le reconnaît il a ses
limites quand ça touche au saint-père et
trouve que ce n'est pas respectueux vous
l'avez dit pour élise lucet des notaires
alors là le pape françois avait eu un
petit accident et que sa papamobile
ah oui on a diffusé les images par souci
d'information et off je peux révéler si
elle n'était pas bien voilà ce qui s'est
passé pendant magnette coup de frein
dans une rue de colombie il a été
légèrement blessé au visage
regarde le tour on peut la voir de la
revoir le tour on collabore pour la voir
mais comme on peut la voir boire c'est
bon c'est bon ça me fait de la peine
le voilà même le mec compatit mais pas
trop un les izards ce cyril cette équipe
ce gala là je sais pas mais vous avez
peut-être voir m'éclairer parce qu'en
fouillant dans les roches
moi je suis tombé sur un extrait étrange
[Applaudissements]
parce locataires parce qu'elle me away
moi je suis contre les jets ou non vous
savez du coup sûr ne pouvait pas passer
cette barre non non
ça aussi c'est pas ça franchement c'est
pas ça non non non non elle n'a pas
compris mènera paix on parlait de zizou
voilà il est jaune devenant je ne
passerai pas mais ça c'est juste que je
les vois là ce sera même pas de ce qui
s'est passé à ses revenus alors vous
dire franchement je connais pas la
passer mes commerçants cap à passer aux
cadets à basse kabylie ouais moi je suis
contre les jets ou bluetooth
[Applaudissements]
il ya la place
[Rires]
je m'étais pas ça c'est vrai on est
courtois et courtois sans jean luc
masset les cater c'est vraiment les
enfants c'est vraiment les offres de
chez aux fans ont vraiment arrêter d'en
boire depuis ses passages parce que l a2
est là vous avez deux chars a changé
mais non c'est déjà beau succès
j'attendais donc le cap que vous avez
deux chattes c'est vrai oui
ouais quand même une chaîne non mais
c'est vrai comment il s'appelle genre il
y en a ils s'appellent tertio les teams
il s'appelle top 20 il s'appelait rectum
parce que ça me dit trop durs n'ont pas
dû l'annoncer
[Applaudissements]
on est dans la thématique enchaînons
avec tout ce qu'on n'aurait pas voulu
voir et entendre cette semaine à c'est
déjà ça et ça commence par maxime gainey
qui comment dire enfin au début de l'an
de ses missions il a pris beaucoup de
confiance de piqué dans l'équipe
le mec se kiffe mais ça va ses camarades
ne l'ont pas remarqué
g
s
je briche
ça va retrouver la santé
gens me remercient
je brille
une
monde
[Musique]
parce que vous gardez le portable de vos
conjoints dont j'ai joué jamais jamais
pas à moi ton cherchons thiam estime que
d'obliger le louvre est pour lui montrer
donc oui la belle prouesse en teck
quelqu'un de bâton de moïse et là on est
rassasié de moi que moi oui merci chers
frères trop fin mai 20 ans mais sans la
raison de ces méchants indiqué que des
critiques moi intérieurement c'est vrai
que sa sortie il est exactement
bonjour messieurs ce n'est déjà fait
quelque chose pour une table et on peut
alors je fais tous les jours
non mais c'est la vie je voulais dire
voilà j'ai travaillé sur le prochain
single de nazim c'est à dire dans le
court on va suivre un bien sûr cyclades
story on vous donnera des nouvelles des
audiences parce que ckac story ça
démarre toujours mollement et après ça
décolle michel vous habitez ou à
vieillevigne
[Rires]
on y est allés ensemble pour un week-end
et c'est pas moi qui ai beaucoup de
bougies mais c'est eux qui sont pas des
lumières intempéries
[Applaudissements]
la fédérale je ne sais comment vois tu
te lèves japonais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour une
qu'est ce que c'est que ces merdes
qu'est ce que c'est c'est merde j'aurais
[Applaudissements]
je suis rigoler c'est tenir si merci
d'être là excellement aujourd'hui excuse
moi pour ta meuf
c'est pas grave j'accepte toutes les
situations bon on y croit j'accepte
toutes les situations évidemment c'est
pas le vrai souci est qu'il y fume pas
pourrait se précise son secret c'est
plutôt sa relation naissante ou pas on
vient de le voir mexique et que maxime
gainey alors est ce qu'il se passe
vraiment quelque chose
oui c'est une vraie question qui obsède
jean-michel car j'avais vu comme ça je
suis sérieux je pense qu'il est amoureux
kelly qu'est jean michel ou gay ni
maintenant jean-michel regarder
[Musique]
il est le gage d'évolution
on dirait on dirait sur les grilles en
direct vous avez les treuils ton sur tf1
les salles série de l'été comme c'est sa
hotte et moi bien je n'aurais jamais mes
terres mais ma femme générique de fin ce
mois
c'est ça c'est ma femme le château des
oliviers je pense que ça me faire
l'année la relation maxime jean michel
c'est vraiment amoureux oui vraiment non
on va mourir oui c'est beau de le dire
ces mots louisien mais j'éprouve quelque
chose je pense que c'est réciproque
kelly oui mais voilà les coûts du dégoût
et moi je vais je veux finir par quitter
cette petite équipe a alors donc je dis
je parle de la relation entre jean
michel et maxime est ce que même quand
ça leur came maxime trouve toujours une
formule malheureuse qui vexe son voisin
la rose faîtière ardisson et tout le
monde avait des lunettes noires
[Musique]
leurs noms
jean missionnaire qui ne supporte plus
rien comment peut on ne peut plus parler
avec les pincettes puisqu'il faut le
prendre avec des pincettes selon michel
nadeau croit pas du tout ça monsieur
[Applaudissements]
chaque fois comme ça oui alors dans
l'équipe cette année je pense que vous
l'avez noté il ya eu un retour très
important celui de bernard montiel qui a
une particularité il connaît tout le
monde l'a fréquenté les dida et je me
sers avec alain delon phedra clip le
général de gaulle alors que moi le
numéro plus connu mon répertoire si
gilles verdez résultat à caen reçoit des
stars il peut alors balancé dû tuer à
tour de bras et pendant la pub compte
nous on joue les teams in lui va taper
la discute c'était mathilde seigner et
richard berry
[Musique]
oui bien sûr
mais l'émirat
tu vois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
cgg manger en face de bernard il a une
haleine alors que john et jehn
irréprochable aussi c'est pas la même
table mais bien c'est comme ça je pense
que je pouvais pas trouver une meilleure
transition pour le top gênante winery là
et là on a pris dans la gueule
cette compilation des moments bizarres
et gênant de touche pas à mon poste
c'est non c'est non
[Musique]
j'allais tentatives pour rendre
aujourd'hui toujours place des
politiques et des arts
[Musique]
c'est chaud
ils sont à venir
super content
je suggère qu'on peut en penser
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
c
yahya yahya
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je souhaiter bon anniversaire à fait
mais c'est vrai que ce sont les mesures
que l'on savait qu ils ont le même agent
plus tôt qu'à moi je vous dis que si
j'étais un mec
[Musique]
merci